I know but you think that marry butter
wouldn't melt but she has been a vandal
quite unexpected bad listen I got
arrested
I actually got arrested what it was I we
were doing them you don't know what
happened was I was we're at the
Birmingham NEC we just finished dinner
demo and I was staying on to a book
signing I Mary left and she walked past
my car I then which is a very posh car
yeah it's nice car yeah and so she came
out I left as she did I came out with
the security and they said Oh have you
seen what's on your car and I went what
you mean what's on my car gonna look at
your car and on this sill of the window
she'd signed look Mary with a sharpie
the police officer was with me turn
around and said do you want to do an
arrested for criminal damage absolutely
we leave it 12 months place so the
following year we were at the NEC and I
saw the same police officer mister
listen we're going on stage in a minute
if you'd like to come on and arrest her
I think you'd better bring for lunch you
might get a bit feisty he went on stage
and I said and then the police officers
came in and they actually Hank after and
[Laughter]
yeah again but in this country this time
yes so I've been married before which I
am married and we had the Islamic
marriage in this country and then we
went out to Bangladesh and had like the
ceremony out there not because we like
we wanted the hot weather or or the
beaches my father-in-law and my dad
decided that they concocted this plan
that would be cheaper to go out there oh
no I said what they were paying for it
no no sensible yeah but we had no I knew
nobody I had no family just my mom and
my dad and my husband who I had only
seen once Wow so as the second time I'd
seen him so I was like yeah he's
good-looking but that's a whole lot of
life time
that's why that's why I want to get
married because I actually actually mean
it this time like last time it was a bit
like let's do this yeah but it's
interesting because I've read in
interviews you're talking about the
whole idea of arranged marriages and the
more I read you talking about it what
are the sensible it seems but did you
kind of think the chances are credibly
the same says that love at first sight
is projection at first sight
it's just that they remind you of
someone else you've you love already so
like usually one of your parents I mean
there's no such thing as love at first
sight but how would you how how could
you love someone you'd never met with no
when I met my wife we shook hands and I
swear it was like being hit by lightning
and it still feels like that and it's
all those years later so alright afraid
I disagree you can write all the
psychology books you like you can't
change how you feel when you meet
somebody my husband had a lovely long
hair and a big ass and I was like that's
nice very we've been out here for how
long have we been here about 30 seconds
probably so I think it's time so what
have you brought us
why did I come well I forgot to buy your
book
[Applause]
today bake-off bake-off you know it
opened all these doors to your knowledge
of honors and things and but one of the
biggest thrills must have been when you
got to bake the the Queen's birthday
cake yeah there you are and you didn't
talk to the moon for long apparently no
no are you sorry are you laughing what
I'm laughing at I'm laughing at that
Lady Mayoress it looks like she's about
to have the whole thing disappear very
quickly so I don't know it could have
happened
No well sorry lady but if you're
watching lady Merritt I know you didn't
need the whole thing you wanted I didn't
know he was there and she's the one
person that I met that made me the most
nervous in fairness yes my dad now
introduces me as this is the daughter
that made the cake for the Queen I don't
even have a name anymore but I didn't
know Prince Phillip was there so he
slaughters around I'm trying to talk
muffling all my words and then he comes
up and he said and the Queen then
introduced me to principal so get in
when she introduces you to somebody else
and they said this is the young lady who
won the baking competition and I was at
this point that was cloud nine and he
comes up yesterday I know who she is but
what flavors the cake over the course of
this series it discovered a dark secret
from the berry history so we had a lot
of time to chat we're together we were
stuck together mainly because I also
followed Mary home but what this is what
I love most about Mary's we all feel
like we know Mary we you know we know
what she's amazing and it was week two
they were making a move soccer takes
time Mary and I sitting there in the
greenroom snuggled under a blanket it
was cold
always the boys didn't like it no no and
we're sitting there and Mary tells me
I'm right here um did I tell you
about when I was arrested quit I swear
to God I just drop what I'm not I don't
just go what and it was 20 about 25 25
years ago and I was asked to go to
America to do cookery demonstration uses
and I'm very particular at getting
everything right and I also try to look
ahead so I thought I ought to have my
recipes all the ingredients weighed out
in case the plane is late or in case the
connections on one go straight on stage
to do my presentation our cookery
demonstration and so I weighed out each
recipe in little bags and everything
together so that I could lift us out for
the first recipe and so on the parts to
the dogs this was my favorite bit when
we arrived there were dogs and I love
dogs and I was in there just ready to go
to them and they all three of them came
up with their noses sort of like this
and they were I thought oh but they
didn't want to know me they just began
and then suddenly the airport became
empty other were just uniformed people
and I was with Lucy young her my
assistant they parted us Lucy there
neither into two cells Mary berry in a
cell with a selection of packets
containing white powder and you see I
didn't know whether they're all purpose
flour was you know the same as our flies
that's yes yeah
this is why marries me because she
wanted to make the the greatest cakes
possible so had it already and is it
true there's my state I was just
incredulous they were like we need you
back on set I was like somebody else is
gonna and didn't he turn to you and say
ma'am are you are you expecting to make
some money from these white packets and
you said oh I do and
[Applause]
[Music]
you